[Music]
tyler perry is an actor
writer director producer and
billionaire but he didn't get to where
he is easily
perry was born into a poor family in new
orleans he was abused as a child
having a painful and lonely adolescence
then
oprah happened hi everybody
she had a segment about how journaling
could be therapeutic and it clicked with
him
writing became his outlet and he
channeled all his hurt
and abuse and rage into letters which
became the inspiration for his first
play
i know i've been changed he moved to
atlanta
and invested his life savings into this
production
it was not a hit
there wasn't anyone in the audience when
it had its opening night in 1992
but perry was determined to not let his
play fail
so he lived out of his car while he
tweaked the production
designing the set making programs
hanging lights
even selling snacks during intermission
his dedication
paid off and the play toured from 1998
to 2000.
he invested his profits into his second
play i can do bad all by myself
that introduced the famous character of
medea which perry played himself
it was supposed to tour only five cities
but audiences
really liked medea
tyler perry played her all around the
country now let's just have this on
record
before he ever had a tv show before he
ever had a movie
tyler perry took in more than 100
million dollars from theater ticket
sales
20 million dollars from merchandise and
another 30 million dollars from videos
of the performances
oprah became a fan of perry inviting him
on her talk show for the first time in
on stage they had an emotional
conversation about resilience
backstage oprah told him the secret to
her success
own everything just like he did with his
first play
tyler perry invested his own money into
his first hollywood movie
and again critics hated it but his fans
showed up in its opening weekend diary
of a mad black woman was number one at
the box office
bringing in nearly 22 million dollars
executives were finally starting to give
credit to tyler perry
two years after diary of a mad black
woman his first tv show house of pain
became the highest rated first run
syndicated cable show of all time
so far he's written and produced more
than 1 200 episodes of television in the
past 15 years
the medea franchise was retired in 2019
those 11 movies grossed more than 670
million dollars
with tyler taking a 290 million dollar
profit
that same year he also opened tyler
perry studios
a 330 acre property in atlanta with 12
sound stages
and custom sets that include a white
house that was built to scale
and he took note of what oprah told him
perry owns the entirety of his creative
output
more than 1 200 episodes of television
22 feature films and at least two dozen
stage plays
oh and viacom cbs pays him 150 million
dollars a year for new content
and he has an equity stake in the
streaming service b-e-t plus
behind the camera or in front of the
camera tyler perry continues to be one
of the highest paid
hardest working and most prolific
multi-hyphenates in the game
[Music]
you